Bob detachment basically tells us if P
then Q okay so this is just a way of
condensed way of writing it but
basically if the hypothesis happens then
the conclusion will happen so if P
happens these three dots mean therefore
therefore Q will happen now the
important thing to remember when you're
working with these laws is that they
flow in the arrow direction so the
direction of the arrow so it doesn't go
against the arrow it's like a river it
goes just that one direction okay so the
law detachment basically involves two
quantities the hypothesis and the
conclusion if the hypothesis happens
then the conclusion will naturally
follow from that now the law of
syllogism is really like the transitive
property you probably learn the
transitive property like if a equals B
and B equals C then a equals C right
well it's very similar here with the law
syllogism if P then Q if Q then R if P
happens meaning this first item then
through this chain of events right R is
gonna occur now sometimes students get a
little bit confused like is that law of
detachment is that law of syllogism well
with law of syllogism you'll notice that
there's three or more quantities
involved whereas law of detachment
there's just two quantities the
hypothesis and the conclusion but here
what happens with the law of syllogism
is that the conclusion ends up becoming
the hypothesis in the next statement
which leads to another conclusion and so
you have that like chain of events so
let me see if I can show you what I mean
in some of these examples here so if you
study then you will get a good grade
makes sense right now you don't want to
overthink this sometimes some of these
problems are gonna be doing their math
class okay with the laws of logic they
don't involve numbers or even like a
figures or even like mathematical
concepts but to try to understand this
better what you want to do is you want
to underline whatever comes after the if
so if you study so you studying that's
the hypothesis whatever comes after the
then I like to underline that's the
conclusion so this is like our P
and this is like our cue so if you study
then you'll get a good grade let's
assume that's true
okay so John studied what can you
conclude well John studied that means
that John must have gotten a good grade
okay honest quiz is test her in his
class right and got a good grade what
can you conclude well in got a good
grade that's actually the conclusion but
we don't know that the fact that she
studied okay we don't know if that
actually is what was the cause of her
getting the good grade okay she may have
not have studied she might just be a
brilliant student and she just naturally
just gets good grades or maybe some
other fact or maybe the teacher said
okay I'm just gonna give everybody an A
okay so what you want to pay attention
to is you don't want to think about it
like creating all these different
scenarios in your head like oh yeah it
makes sense you know you want to think
about is the hypothesis being triggered
then the conclusion will naturally
follow from that okay so if this is a
true conditional statement a true
if-then statement it flows this
direction okay not the other way so here
what happened went and got a good grade
okay
you cannot conclude that she's studied
okay even though she may have but we
can't make that conclusion and this is
actually what's called the converse area
you're saying it in Reverse okay and
that's not necessarily true let's go on
to another example if you study then
you'll get a good grade if you get a
good grade then you will go to the next
class okay so notice what's happening
here after the if that's our hypotheses
study whatever's after the then that's
our conclusion you're going to get a
good grade but then look what happens if
you get a good grade okay so that
conclusion becomes the hypothesis in the
next statement okay then you will go on
to the next class okay so again if you
want to diagram this out I would call
this P this Q this is Q because you can
see we're repeating that statement and
then it causes R which is going on to
the next class so just like we diagram
out here P causes q Q causes our so
through that chain of events
P happens it will cause our to occur
okay so you're with me so far
so here if we say Sally studied what can
you conclude if Sally studied well if
she studied then she's going to get a
good grade because she's getting a good
grade she's going to go on to the next
class so all you have to state is that
okay since Sally studied the conclusion
is Sally went on to the next class
whereas this one here John went on to
the next class does that mean that John
got a good grade doesn't mean that he
studied those things may or may not be
true but we can't conclusively make that
argument this is an invalid argument
okay so John went on to the next class
no conclusion we really don't know you
know if you studied if you got a good
grade if any of these other things
happen that's going against against the
direction of these arrows it's like
going from R to Q to Q to P only thing
we conclude for certain for a 100% is
that it's going this direction okay the
direction of the arrow let's look at one
last example if you're enjoying these
videos go ahead and subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
I've got more videos like this coming
for you I want to help you in your math
class I want you to get good grades and
um you know make it less stressful for
you that's my goal behind all these
videos so go ahead and you know like
this video more importantly subscribe
but let's look at one more example so I
can help you to understand the law of
syllogism and the law of detachment
so here the last one if you get up late
you will miss the bus okay so let's just
say Mario misses the bus does that mean
that I got up late no right because
we're going in Reverse that's the
converse error but if I get up late so
say like Bob got up late well can you
conclude Bob missed the bus
so assuming that this is true you don't
want to start getting into this idea of
like just trying to like logic and
reason it out in your mind saying well
you know maybe maybe John was able to
you know make up some time by you know
he's not brushing his teeth that day and
you know then running to the bus stop
and catching the bus no you just have to
take it at face value have to say okay
whatever comes after that if getting up
late
what does that cause getting up late
well then you're gonna miss the bus
so we're just gonna say miss the bus so
that's the only thing you can really
conclude assuming this is true the
hypothesis will cause a conclusion but
not the other way around
that's the law of detachment I hope you
enjoyed this video go ahead and
subscribe I'll see you in the next video